russia launching an all-out invasion on
ukraine battering the country from land
air and sea that scene from earlier
today vladimir putin ordering airstrikes
on cities and military bases sending in
tanks and troops from three different
directions the russian invasion so far
has killed nearly 60 people with that
number set to rise and a u.s official
warning russia's goal is to decapitate
the ukrainian government and says what
we are seeing now is the first strike of
many to come the ukrainians are fighting
back trey yanks is reporting live from
the ukrainian capital of kiev good
morning
good afternoon the russian offensive
against ukraine continues at this hour
we are seeing reports of renewed
fighting and clashes in a number of
different locations today just outside
the capital of kiev there was a back and
forth between russian and ukrainian
forces the russians brought in attack
helicopters taking over a strategic
airfield we are learning this evening
according to the ukrainian ministry of
defense that airfield has been
recaptured by ukrainian forces that was
not the case in other parts of the
country including the north where in the
chernobyl region russian troops crossed
over from belarus and they were able to
advance against ukrainian forces and
take over that position
in the eastern part of the country there
is still fighting but it is uh in
different pockets across the donetsk and
luhans regions these are the separatist
controlled areas of eastern ukraine that
were used as part of this offensive as
president putin ordered an invasion
across the entire country and then in
the south russian forces worked their
way up through crimea trying to make
basically what will look like a land
bridge so that they can hit the capital
of kiev from a number of different
angles if they do indeed launch that
larger invasion to try to
basically take the capital and make sure
that it does not have any support from
the other ukrainian troops who are still
operating within the country dana trey
we have some questions for you and we
know you've been working all day and are
very trying conditions so we thank you
for being with us on the five i'll take
it uh kick it over to jesse waters first
hey trey
the vibe right now in the capitol it's
got to be like being at the alamo
you know you know you're going to be
surrounded and you're outnumbered what
are people thinking how are they feeling
do people regret not leaving soon enough
take us through it
we learned today from the interior
minister that more than 10 000 weapons
were given out to civilians who have
pledged to stay here and fight there's a
real understanding that if these russian
forces are able to choke off the
ukrainian capital as they are suspected
to do in the coming days this will turn
into a more urban warfare situation and
you will see ukrainian forces in
somewhat of a guerrilla warfare format
because they will have to try to protect
the capital and the head of government
the concern that the ukrainian military
has at this hour is that what we saw
last night and throughout the day today
the air raid sirens and strikes not only
on the capital of ukraine but also the
second largest city kharkiv and other
major ukrainian
cities and population centers is that
they could launch more waves of attacks
and it would ultimately overwhelm the
forces that are outside in these
different military locations so if the
fight does come into the city it will
look very different it will be far
bloodier and that death toll will
certainly rise jesse
geraldo
trey great job very courageous you and
the rest of our mates over there wish i
was standing shoulder to shoulder with
you uh you know you're experienced
enough to get the vibe
are the ukrainians determined to fight
this out are they going to fight to the
death are they really going to you know
put it all out there right now or will
they fold in the face of the
overwhelming superiority of russian arms
they are determined to fight it out but
we are getting some new information this
hour that's really important when you
think about their chances fighting the
russian military ukraine's armed forces
believe that more than 60 russian
tactical battalion groups have been used
in this fight so far we're talking about
30 000 to 60 000 troops remember there
are nearly 200 000 russian soldiers
along ukraine's border so even if they
take heavy losses in a more urban
environment or if some of these reports
that we are seeing from the eastern part
of ukraine of these javelin anti-tank
missiles actually doing their job and
stopping these battalions from getting
closer to the larger population centers
it still might not be enough it may be
too little too late in terms of the
weaponry that the ukrainian forces have
they no longer according to the russians
have any air defense systems we have not
seen any air defense in the capital
since we have been reporting here but we
do hear fighter jets uh often in this
city and still tonight there are strikes
taking place and ukrainian officials are
worried that as we get closer to 3 a.m
local time that's the time they are
putting out that another campaign an air
campaign against this city will take
place
judge jeanine
first of all our thoughts and prayers
are with the ukrainians and with their
families all over the world i think we
have to recognize the pain that this
country is in but given what you've said
about arming the citizenry
do the people in ukraine understand
that ultimately
it doesn't seem like the cavalry's
coming in to save them that they are
literally at war
with an aggressor who has done this in
front of the whole world he lined it up
he's been lining this up for weeks with
tanks and and soldiers and and the truth
is that there is no way other than a
sanction here or there to stop him is is
keeve the end game here
it's certainly the end game here
president putin does not want ukrainian
president voldemor zielinski to be
running this country
at best he wants some sort of puppet
regime that he would be able to control
much like we are seeing in belarus where
the president there alexander lukashenko
has
called russia and belarus basically the
same country president putin would like
that situation at a minimum to take
place in ukraine what's interesting
though when you talk to the civilians
here who have pledged to stay and fight
they understand just how gruesome and
violent this war could be already the
death toll is rising and some of the
images that we are seeing
from the fighting in the eastern part of
the country and even some of the strikes
and and missile strikes that took place
in
and around larger population centers
it's quite gruesome the uh ability of
the russian military against a civilian
population would be quite bloody and so
while there is this patriotic push for
ukrainians to say we will stay and fight
and protect our homeland
it is going to be very very difficult to
do so when there are russian tanks in
the streets but make no mistake these uh
civilians that we talked to and even the
soldiers who have been called up from
reserve forces say they will stay and
they will fight and they are willing to
die for their country and we have heard
that message again and again not only
here in the capitol but also when we
were visiting the front lines in the
eastern part of ukraine
will kane
trey just to get a sense of that
resistance you've been covering this
wonderfully all week long we saw you
embedded with those forces in the east
when you were taking fire i'm curious
have you managed to stay in
communication with those forces in the
east do you know what the resistance is
like how quickly the russians are moving
what kind of casualties even from where
you were earlier in the week
we understand there are a lot of
casualties in the east the russians use
those russian-backed separatists to move
up those lines very quickly and from
what we saw out on the front they were
literally in trenches
in terms of the ability of a russian air
strike from a fighter jet
to
to target someone like this in a trench
they have very limited places to go
and it looks like that on a lot of the
ukrainian front remember that line of
contact has been there since 2015 when
there was a peace agreement cut between
the russian-backed separatists and the
ukrainians still a bloody conflict with
nearly 14 000 deaths since it began in
2014
but we do fear some of those people that
we were with over the weekend
may be injured or killed given the fact
that this offensive has moved so quickly
and the russian air power has been quite
significant we are talking about not
only fighter jets targeting different
locations cruise missiles ballistic
missiles and those ground forces again
the ukrainians are putting up a fight
and they have uh hit a number of these
battalions that are coming in across the
border using anti-tank missiles and
other weaponry but the reality is this
is already a bloody war and it could get
far worse in the coming hours and days
as the russians are expected to launch
more waves of attacks
trey i just have a question that is more
i think something our viewers might be
wondering as they've watched you and
steve lucas tomlinson covering this uh
conflict
how do you stay safe
i mean look fox is built by people who
used to be field producers and so the
executives at this company understand
the importance of getting into the field
but also staying safe in the field so we
have a massive team working with us not
only here in the capital but we have
four teams on the ground in ukraine
right now and everything is very
calculated we have safety plans in place
and we execute those plans each and
every day and we did last night when
this massive invasion started the real
story here though
is not the journalist it's not us it's
the people of ukraine it's the civilians
who are picking up arms to defend their
country tonight it is the women and
children who are currently sleeping in
the subway system of this capital city
because they are worried about air
campaigns and it's the soldiers on the
front lines who are currently risking
their lives for the sovereignty of
ukraine well you are bringing us their
stories so well trey yanks thank you no
doubt we'll see you a little bit later
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else